cuéntenos Cuáles son desde su punto de
vista no por estos momentos los
problemas más acuciantes para los
nicaragüenses que se pueden ver
reflejados en estas cifras
Sí hay varias razones lo primero que hay
que decir es que este deterioro ha sido
progresivo es decir la encuesta lo que
hace es remarcar una tendencia al
deterioro en todos los planos de la
dictadura de Ortega y hay varias razones
por un lado un pueblo religioso
mayoritariamente católico al que se le
prohíben las actividades religiosas más
elementales Incluso en semana santa que
se encarcela exilia o se declaran
expatriados a sacerdotes a obispos pues
naturalmente se lastima en las fibras
más sensibles del ser humano el
territorio sagrado de la conciencia en
segundo lugar hay elementos materiales
la carestía de la vida de acuerdo con
las mismas cifras oficiales más del 50
por ciento de la laboral se encuentra en
subempleo o desempleo más el ambiente
represivo opresivo que se ha impuesto en
el país Entonces si uno tiene una
circunstancia política opresiva una
persecución al nivel de la conciencia y
condiciones materiales que no ofrecen
ninguna posibilidad de respiro ni de
Esperanza Es natural que esas que esas
realidades se expresen en encuestas de
opinión claro Enrique según esta
encuesta de frente sandinista registra
el 13% de simpatía partidario lo que
representa su nivel histórico más bajo
en las últimas dos décadas acá atribuye
usted Esta caída del movimiento
precisamente a las razones que
mencionaba que también afectan a quienes
han respaldado a Ortega Igualmente ellos
no tienen empleo Igualmente ellos
padecen el impacto de la carestía de la
vida y hay varias evidencias de que esto
no solo es una declaración frente a un
encuestador sino que todos los días casi
en los medios de comunicación en las
redes sociales se registran a ex
simpatizantes de la dictadura que
aparecen en Estados Unidos acogido al
programa humanitario que se llama parole
es decir No solo se trata de una opinión
sino que incluso sectores que
respaldaban a Ortega prefieren el
Imperio como le llama Ortega al paraíso
que sigue dibujando o pretendiendo
dibujar el dictador a sus seguidores a
los pocos seguidores que le van quedando